[Music]
so let's play e4 that that is the move
that most people actually play
and e5 so knight f3
and i unfortunately i can't satisfy
everybody in terms of like the opening
that we play i know people play
different stuff
trust me i know that but i like to
showcase
different openings and how to play them
and an opening that i've wanted to play
today
is the scotch uh yeah i do give rarity
to subs
uh and the scotch is the move d4 in this
position now
this gotcha is an opening that i do
recommend to beginners
among the openings i recommend is that
the only one
uh because the scotch in the words of my
friend peter
peter who streams at the head of the
charlotte chess center who streams at
charlotte chess center because he's
asleep i will allow myself to say
something nice about him
which normally isn't the case when he's
in the stream check out history
just uh instructional streams twice a
week
uh and they're really good so give them
a follow trust me if you're
interested in chess improvement it is
definitely worth it
uh i don't put my name behind a lot of
people but
uh he's he's great at explaining
concepts and stuff so
uh supporting you know by a follow he
would really appreciate
but um essentially the scotch teaches
you to play with all of your pieces
because what the move d4 does is it
opens up the center
and think of it this way when the center
is closed you
kind of have a crutch it's important to
know how to play when the center is
closed when the center is closed there's
less likelihood of blundering pieces
there is less let's just say
head-to-head combat
between the pieces when the center is
open it teaches you the importance of
having all of your pieces on good
squares
it teaches you the importance of active
development and it allows you
uh to you know basically you get
punished for your mistakes which when
you're a beginner is kind of important
so d6 is kind of passive
that's not a terrible move but what
makes this move passive who can explain
to me
why this is a passive move the reason is
quite simple
because the good thing about this move
is it opens up one bishop but in opening
up one bishop
it blocks the other you've got to be
careful about that it blocks the dark
squared bishop so now it can only come
to e7
which is not the sexiest square it's a
it's a serviceable square it's not
terrible
which is why this move is not terrible
but it's not uh you know
10 out of 10 kind of square 10 out of 10
square would be bishop c5
which is one of the main moves or knight
to f6 which is the other what should we
do
well let's just develop our knight no
rocket science here and now we need to
develop our bishops now where would this
bishop go where do you guys propose
assuming that he develops his knight
which i think he will
but even if he doesn't in general where
should this bishop go
yeah so there's two squares that you
guys should be considering that's the
squares b5 and c4 so
i like the move bishop b5 less
and i know that this will be surprising
to a lot of people because people really
like pins and you should like pens
but not all pins are effective and the
problem with bishop to b5
is that he's going to unpin himself with
bishop to d7
and that pin is going to be kind of
empty right there's going to be no more
pin
and that bishop on b5 is going to be
sort of staring at the knight and the
trade
is not particularly good instead let's
drop our bishop on c4
and this bishop is quite a bit better
because it has the sustained pressure
that it's mounting on the f7 pawn now
again chess is a gradual game you're not
gonna checkmate anybody
with one developing move so it's not
like we are threatening to take the pawn
on f7 we are applying
long-term pressure on it we are
basically setting up for a potential
attack which may involve this bishop
it's controlling a lot of squares
and he goes g6 to fianchetto his bishop
now let's consider this bishop where
should this bishop go
where should this bishop go
oh we have an even sexier move though
okay but this is kind of advanced but
it's it's it's really cool you guys
want me to do it want me to walk you
through the logic now the correct
the sort of the development of bishop to
g5 but
let me try to explain how i see this
rather than just playing the moves
do you guys see the position of the
queens in the starting position the
queens are and i call this a standoff
a standoff is when two pieces are facing
each other but there's
more than one piece blocking them if
there's only one piece blocking them and
it's your piece
it's a it's an x-ray now when the two
pieces are at a standoff there is a
tactical potential
if the position opens up if the pieces
between them somehow disappear
then the pieces are going to be directly
facing each other so i notice
that the queens are in a standoff not
only are the queens in a standoff but
black's queen
is defended by two pieces it is defended
first of all by the knight
and second of all by the king
hypothetically
how can i get this king out of e8 can i
decoy this king
from its defense of the d8 queen of the
queen
yeah bishop f7 but not immediately if a
situation arises when the queens are
staring at each other i could do that
can i get the knight out of c6 so i need
i need two more things i need to get the
knight out of c6 let's take it
and there's only one thing preventing me
from being able to take on f7 and that
is the d6 pawn
and to the rescue comes another decoy
sacrifice
where we play knight where we play the
move e5 attacking the knight
and if he doesn't take our pawn then
this pawn is going to wreak havoc
if he does then we play bishop captures
f7
and he doesn't and we'll talk about this
distracting the king from the queen he
didn't have to take the bishop there
but his position would have been ruined
regardless okay
so abraham goes goes uh d5 counter
attacking harbish now should we take the
knight
and those of you who are often in my
stream know that when i ask that
question
i'm oh actually we have a better move
and tobias found it
so we can in general we should because
that opens up the position
but let's put it this way we have a
better way of taking that knight
the better way of taking that knight
good job tobias
is is the move bishop g5 so conceptually
we should take the knight
but we should do it with the bishop
which would fork
uh if he takes our bishop then we can
actually take his knight immediately but
we can also take his queen first
and then that bishop is going to be
forking the rook and the queen or the
rook of the cane
but in general the reason that we should
take the knight when our opponent is
less developed than we are
and here he's got both of his bishops
undeveloped and he's not even close to
castling
the side that is the furthest away from
castling
is the side that often stands to lose
when the center is opened
why because when the center is opened
that e file can often be used
to check an exposed king bishop to e7
what should we take the knight with
remember our bishop is hanging we got to
be careful
what should we take the night with
we should take the night with a pawn if
we take the night with a bishop he takes
our bishop
and then he takes the other bishop and
material is equal if we take the pawn
then he can at most only get a pawn for
the bishop if he takes the bishop
then we're going to take his bishop and
we are going to remain up a piece
so yeah okay now now we should trade
and now we need to move our bishop away
after he takes with the queen we need to
move our bishop away from c4 because it
was getting attacked
uh where should we move it it doesn't
really matter uh this is a less
essential decision let's just drop it
out to d3
so it's sort of in the vicinity of the
king in casey castled
and of course we also need to castle
castle castle
and we are up a piece now is the
conversion stage we are converting our
advantage in being up a piece is in sort
of grand master terms a decisive
advantage now as i've explained during
my initial speed run there are two
fundamental methods
overarching methods of converting an
extra piece or more
the first is to trade as many pieces as
possible try what you're essentially
aiming
for in the end is getting a situation
where you just have
your extra piece and a bunch of pawns
against your opponent's king and a bunch
of pawns that makes it easier
because then that extra piece is just
going to like have
target practice against the pawns and
that's going to be easier to win
the second method is to use your extra
piece as kind of another soccer player
and mount an attack against the opposing
king which
by definition is going to be good
because you have more
pieces in the attack you literally have
more pieces here we can try to apply
either method we can play queen to c1
we can play queen to c1 and threaten the
queen trade or we can try to open up
the ken now the method that is usually
taught by coaches
is the trade method but i actually want
to push back on that slightly what often
happens to players
is they try too hard to trade all of the
pieces
and in doing so they forget that the you
know they make a mistake
here we're actually going to attack
black's game now to attack black's king
we need to open up some files around it
and so the move f4 followed by f5 trying
to open that f-file
which would offer us an avenue to
black's king
that seems to me to be the best move
sorry that was a long explanation
my bad but uh hopefully that makes sense
just remember that trading pieces is not
the only way of converting an advantage
uh trying to attack your opponent's king
is also a full-fledged alternative
method
of converting many positions oftentimes
it's better it's just quicker and it's
it's it's more effective
and f5 we shove this pawn to f5 we
sacrifice it
take my pawn by all means if he takes it
with his pawn
he ruins the pawn structure around his
king if he takes it with a bishop then
we take his bishop
and once again he's going to end up
having to take with a pawn if he doesn't
take with a pawn okay now he may be
making a weakness
now we need to apply something i taught
you guys a little bit earlier we ask
after an important move like this how
has the position changed
what squares are now available to some
of our pieces
if we look very carefully ah the g5 the
move g5
opens up the h5 square for our queen
which is a great attacking position
i'm gonna have to play a little bit
faster uh just because i don't have much
time
okay so bishop takes f5 is a blunder but
black is is kind of losing anyway now we
have one
two attackers on that square and only
one defender let's take with a rook
we take with a rook to involve the rook
in the attack although we could have
taken to the bishop
and the game is over we're up two pieces
and we're checkmating him
check that is not a scary check not all
checks are scary
we just tuck the king away in the corner
our king is perfectly safe
and we are up two pieces and we're gonna
use them to deliver checkmate
but we can do it in a nice way so what
do i see here
boom and boom
the bishop and the queen are both aimed
at the h7
pawn where should we take that logic
well
we take that logic and we transform it
into a move by saying well if the rook
was gone from f5
then queen takes h7 would be checkmate
right because it just would
so we need to move the rook away now do
we just put it on anywhere no
the ideal kind of move is to move the
rook away with check he has to respond
to the check
and so then we deliver checkmate yeah
now the second best move would be to
move the rook away and attack the queen
simultaneously that would be second best
because
technically he could give up the queen
rook takes g5 is literally forced to
checkmate he has to either take the rook
or move the king away because he is in
check and then queen takes h7 is going
to be made
yeah good game good game abraham
and another very instructive game
okay
so good game good game
that was the most well thank you for
playing i know it's i
realize it's it's it's nerve-wracking to
play in front of
you know thousands of people literally
but but you played well
so you made for an instructive opponent
yes
so d4 is the scotch and the scotch is
named the scotch i
actually think it is named after
scotland uh
and i obviously but uh sometimes
openings have weird names that aren't
necessarily named after like the first
person to play the opening uh but the
city of edinburgh
in scotland was one of the first the
sort of what used to be popular in the
1800s is
two cities uh the chess clubs of two
cities would basically play a
correspondence game against each other
they would like mail each other moves
like the members of each chess club
would together come up with the moves
and so the city of edinburgh
faced off against the city of london in
1824 and they were
among the first the members of the club
were among the first to play the scotch
but a couple people had played the
scotch before
now here's the cool thing i'm gonna blow
your mind
i will preface this by saying that the
veracity of this game is disputed like
whether this game actually happened is
subject to debate
i read about this but do you guys know
according to my database
who the first person to play the scotch
was in the year 1818
it's pretty mind-blowing nobody is
expecting me unless somebody knows this
to say this name napoleon yes
you guys know napoleon napoleon
bonaparte
who was an avid chess player that part
is not disputed and that's not
surprising
but according to my database in 1818 he
played a game against
general bertrand already while he was
banished to saint helena
but i read about this and apparently
there's a very famous chess historian
edward winter
who claims that these games didn't
actually happen it was just sort of made
up
to um you know to add to the legend of
napoleon
but um if the game did happen then he
was the first person to play the scotch
according to historical record
and um yeah but anyways it was played a
couple
a couple times before the city of
edinburgh played it
and um the scotch is a very sound
opening because it opens up the diagonal
for the bishop and it opens up the
center
it's played by a lot of grandmasters i
played the scotches in my main opening
until i was about 1700
or 1800 then i switched to the right
lopez
so the move d6 i already explained why
it's not the best
uh because that it blocks the bishop so
i would um
i would you know encourage bishop c5
that's that's one of the main moves
that's what charlie played against xqc
the charlie xqc game was a scotch xqc
played c3
charlie deployed his queen to f6
he just lost whoa that's exactly what we
practiced for
exactly what we practiced for yeah so
xqc may or charlie made it in with queen
takes f2
and uh that was the scotch that doesn't
mean the scotch is about opening i don't
know if xcc is ever going to play it
again
but in this position bishop e3 is the
best move that's actually theory
and um i love that video too trust me
and i think so does charlie
most people love that video i think i'm
responsible for like
a couple thousand of its millions of
views anyways
um so bishop c5 is possible and
you know hikaru didn't like the
variational approach and i think knight
f6
is also possible here this is a more
let's just say classical move because
you develop the knight before the bishop
but from a theoretical perspective the
moves are equivalent
the moves are equivalent in in strength
all right yeah if knight takes c6 then
black can play queen f6 anyway
black and play queen f6 anyway
uh and this isn't this is an
intermediate move it threatens checkmate
white has to attend to the checkmate and
then black recaptures the knight
okay so d6 knight c3 we develop our
pieces and g6 is a big mistake
the reason g6 is a mistake is because
black cannot afford abraham you in this
position the thing is you can't afford
to take two moves to develop your bishop
and you know that now
but uh bishop e7 would be the best move
i get that the bishop is passive here
but this is better than you know than
developing slowly because at least you
get to castle and
black is slightly worse white has better
development here but at least black is
solid
it's a solid position it's not easy for
white to win the game
fast okay
so g6 and now i explained fully the
logic behind this move knight takes c6
and e5 now let's take a look at what
happens if d takes e5
so as i explained we play bishop takes
f7
and if king takes f7 then queen takes d8
there is one very important detail in
this position
sometimes allowing this is actually fine
for black
you guys what losing the queen like that
is fine like well there is an opening
called the danish gambit the danish
gambit is where you sacrifice a bunch of
puns in the i'm going to skip forward to
the important part
so this position frequently occurs in
the danish gambit and here black has the
moon knight f6
why does this look like a big mistake
who can tell me this looks like exactly
the kind of
exactly the kind of moment we just had
but wait a second right bishop f7
and if king f7 then you lose your queen
but wait a second
this isn't the same as this
what's the key difference there's
several superficial differences the key
difference
is the positioning of this knight on c3
the knight being on c3 here the knight
is on p1
and the knight being on b1 allows bishop
before check
this wins back the queen white has to
drop the queen back to avoid
losing it entirely at least white gets
the piece back for it
and this is a very famous endgame it's
about equal material is now equal as a
result
so black can actually fall into this
deliberately and win back the queen
but with the knight being on c3 um
none of this works bishop b4 is no
longer a check you can still play bishop
before
but it loses all of its effectiveness it
just drops the rook
so part of the reason the chess gets
complicated is because
a lot of chess mastery consists
in perceiving these very small details
it's very important to be
detail-oriented
it's very important to compare various
positions because eventually you get
better at spotting these kinds of things
okay um
so can't hide the queen yeah yeah so e5
d5
yeah and in this position black should
move the king up in order to not
lose the queen but i can even still take
the queen and look at how horrible
black's pawns are and the king is
exposed i can pin the knight
white is just much better here so that's
just
good for white and so abram plays d5 we
go bishop g5
and if if pawn takes bishop then of
course we can take the queen
and take the knight and this is a fork
and it's a devastating fort because the
king has to move or bishop blocks and
then we take the rock
okay yeah i'm not off the cam here
okay sorry i was leaning back in my
chair
let me move up again okay so
hopefully that makes sense bishop b7 we
win the peace
trade bishop back castle castle and now
f4 opening up the f-file
f5 forcing a weakness queen h5
exploiting that weakness okay so how
would we have attacked if black just
let's say develop the bishop
this pawn on g5 um prevents a very sexy
rook lift from happening
we can still lift the rook up to f3 and
h3 but we can also make the very typical
move h where when you're attacking you
want to open up the position of your
opponent's king
and a good way to do that would be h4 if
he takes and we can drop the rook to f4
and then either give a check or take on
h4 and
in either case the attack is absolutely
devastating because the moment that the
queen moves
we can now open up the bishop with f6
and the attack is just
absolutely crushing here so there's
really nothing to
to even discuss here but abraham takes
an f5 this hastens the defeat i mean
although
yeah the position is tough even out
without it and now rook takes g5 is a
simple discovery and queen takes h7
is checkmate so short but sweden
again thanks for putting yourself out
there that was a very instructive game
i really appreciate it abraham
[Music]